hi everybody good afternoon thank you uh
thank you for being here and thank you
to to Daniel and Liz and to Andrew uh
awesome talks so far really uh really
appreciate that a lot of good info in
there uh welcome everybody's coming in
and uh thank you for coming to see me uh
my name is Patrick tennet and the title
of my talk is Serenity Now productivity
later
so I'm going to start with a with a
quick story and I think it's one you're
going to you're going to
recognize it's uh it's early one morning
my daughters have just left for school
and so my house is still and
quiet it's about 7: a.m. so I've just
poured my fourth cup of
coffee and I'm ready to rock and roll
you know I'm I'm excited I'm I'm feeling
positive about the day looking forward
to getting a lot of stuff done I go
upstairs and I I sit down at my desk and
I open my work email and boom a flood of
messages from my boss right she's got
new project ideas she's got additions to
existing projects she got additions to
those additions right there's there's a
lot of stuff in my inbox this morning
and uh and I start thinking you know I
had enough to do today already I I did
not need more on my on my project
stack and as I start to go through these
uh these new suggestions these new ideas
I feel just sort of
like this right I'm going to I'm going
to call this feeling deflated but I
actually just don't know the word in
English that is as accurate as this for
the feeling that I have in that moment
where you just you're Zapped right
you've sort of lost your motivation your
excitement for the day you're just
feeling like man I I am overwhelmed and
I almost want to do nothing just because
I have so much to do so I I tell you the
story uh CU like I said I think it's
probably recognizable to many of you uh
we all sort of have have this uh this
moment where we feel overwhelmed and and
kind of want to pull in right rather
than do more we we want want to pull in
uh that deflated loss of momentum loss
of motivation
feeling uh now my talk today is about
something we can do about that something
my team has learned uh that has helped
us to address this feeling and and the
things that lead to it uh but but really
I want to step back first and uh talk
about just that which is like why does
this happen right where is this feeling
coming from uh cuz you might just think
well your boss is the villain right she
sends you all these new ideas and she
makes you feel overwhelmed that's the
problem you need a new boss but in my
case at least that's that's really not
the problem I really like my boss um and
I really think the fact that she has all
these good ideas is a good thing right
it's a good characteristic for a boss to
have and so I I'm not going to blame her
and even if in your version of that
story uh you know whatever the details
are in your version of that story you
feel like you're your boss really is the
problem what I'm going to suggest to you
is that that is not a super helpful
frame to put on the problem uh then
maybe you should think about this a
little bit differently because if that's
your frame the only real answer is to
get a new boss and sometimes that's not
a good idea sometimes it's not possible
uh but generally I just I think there's
a a more agentic way we can think about
this right there's a way that kind of
puts you more in the driver's seat and
that's to think about what is happening
inside of you when that flood of
messages comes in right why is it that
this flood of messages is giving us this
defl feeling where where we've lost all
our all of our momentum and motivation
in the moment uh and so that's what I
want to talk about I want to talk about
like what is what is that cycle for you
and and how my team has learned to get
out of it and how I hope uh you can you
can get out of it yourself so I'm going
to propose that the thing that is
happening inside of all of us in that
moment is fomo our old friend fomo uh a
pretty common idea in in American
Society at least uh but you might not
have thought of this fear of missing out
uh so much in the business context
before or in the professional context
but I think it really does apply right
there's a way in which this really maps
cleanly on to our experience uh and that
you know we're we're afraid of missing
out on a promotion or a raise or a bonus
right we're afraid of missing out on an
opportunity to make our boss happy or
make our team look good right so that
that fomo that is uh you know applied in
the business setting uh is what's
leading us to take on more than we
should right to accept that overwhelming
stack of projects to to try to roll with
that because we're afraid of missing out
on any one of them and in doing so we
actually just lead ourselves to that
deflated place right so I'm I'm
proposing that that fomo is really the
problem here and actually it's even
worse than that because in data science
I think we have a very very specific
acute version of this that would be fomu
adapa that is the uh the fear of missing
out on awesome data science
projects uh so this is this is specific
to us right this is this is our room and
this is this is our version of fomo and
I think it's one that we have for some
really good reasons actually uh because
because in data science we have this
sort of unlimited Universe of data that
we could use right everybody everybody
talks about it all the time there's more
data that we could possibly lay hands on
and then we have all of these awesome
tools that we can use to do great things
with all of that data that's really what
this conference is right this conference
is about having the amazing tools and
the great team that allow us to do great
things with this universe of data that
unlimited landscape right makes fomo
really really acute cuz you don't know
if that next thing if that next version
of this project that next model that
next run of this iterative process is
going to get you to that awesome thing
right uh the the beautifully produced
video we we saw this morning before the
keynote talks about cleaning rivers or
uh getting us to the Moon right these
are these are Big amazing things so I I
don't say this gly I mean it genuinely
there are really really important
projects that we can do but because of
this unlimited landscape we feel like we
need to do more and so that's that's
what I'm talking about today is that
feeling that we feel like we need to do
more and that leavs us to take on more
than we can and to feel overwhelmed and
to feel deflated so my suggestion is
that we actually do less right it might
feel like we need to do more but let's
do less uh and this is you know not a
totally novel idea you've probably come
across this in some form or fashion
before there's uh a lot of of research
backing it up a pretty robust literature
around this idea uh you know book
chapters whole books in fact uh and of
course there is a Harvard Business
review article on exactly this uh want
to be more productive try doing less so
simple thank you hbr uh I'm actually
just G to wrap it up with a quote that I
really like that I think sums all of
this up pretty well uh which is from
Shane Parish who writes the awesome
farum Street blog he says the most
powerful productivity tool ever invented
is simply the word no right that's uh
that's nice right but but uh it's kind
of deceptively simple and it makes it
sound like all you have to do is say no
right just say no uh it is of course not
actually all that easy saying no is hard
uh we have this fomo we don't want to
say no and then you add this layer where
your boss or my boss in this case is
sending all of these ideas so the person
we have to say no to is the boss right
this is exactly the person you don't
want to say no to so so the rest of this
is my story of how I learn to say no to
the
boss and that's when we get to the
Eisenhower Matrix so the Eisenhower
Matrix is named for former president
Dwight Eisenhower uh and it's basically
a task management tool it's a pretty
simple idea it's been around for a long
time as you can probably tell it's name
for Dwight Eisenhower uh so we have uh a
task management tool in which we're
raing our tasks on urgency and
importance right so each task is getting
a rating on each of these
characteristics and then we're just
laying them out on a grid nothing so
complicated about this uh imagine you
have four tasks and uh they're they're
rated like this and so we would think
about each task one by one and it's
going to help guide us to to sort of our
next step for that task task one here uh
very urgent and very important this
deserves your time and attention right
this is where you will focus uh because
it is both important enough to Merit
that but also urgent enough that you
need to do it now task two is very
urgent not all that important in the
Eisenhower Matrix this is something
you're going to delegate right this is
something you're going to hand off to
somebody else because it might not be
important enough to Merit your direct
attention but it's urgent it needs to
get done so we will delegate it task
three not urgent or important bye-bye uh
simple answer for this one in the
Eisenhower Matrix is that we cut it from
our task list right this does not get
anybody's attention and task four uh
this is something that is important but
not super urgent you're going to
schedule this so this gets built into
your long-term plans you build out work
plans for it you put it on your calendar
uh you you make sure this happens
because it's important but it doesn't
have to happen this moment so you're uh
so you're scheduling it so I came across
this and I thought you know this is
really good this is really going to help
me and I tried to implement it I went
through a few rounds of sort of trying
to use this tool and I kept tweaking it
and adapting it until I felt like I'd
gotten to something different right so I
I went from calling it the Eisenhower
Matrix to calling it The Gonzalez Matrix
uh I named it for my boss and I promise
you she is thrilled with this
honor but like I said I I tweaked it I
adapted enough that I felt like it was
it was uh something different uh and so
in in this case rather than urgency and
importance I'm focusing on effort and
value right how effortful is is
something and and how valuable is it and
rather than tasks I'm thinking about
projects right we've moved from the task
level to the project level because
that's what made most sense for my team
that's kind of how we work and it made
sense to to keep and cut uh at the
project level uh so here uh high value
low effort project this is great this is
where we focus this is where we want our
attention and as many of these as we can
get is what really what we want uh
because we're producing a whole lot of
value without putting in a whole lot of
work project two is the one that we're
scheduling in this version of this uh
very effortful uh but also very valuable
so so worth it uh because it's more
effortful it's probably going to require
iterations and collaboration right so
you're building this into work plans and
you're really sort of establishing how
this is going to go long
term project three High effort low value
bye-bye uh we don't want anything to do
with project three because it it does
not Merit that level of effort and
project four uh is the one that we would
maybe delegate right we'd think about
handing this off to a junior member of
the team perhaps because it is uh you
know it's it's not so valuable that if
it doesn't go well it's going to really
hurt the team uh but it's also not so
effortful that it's going to uh
interfere with more important things
right so this is a good good learning
ground for somebody who's uh who's
coming up through the ranks um and so it
could be one that you would delegate to
to them
uh so at this point I want to
acknowledge something which is that this
is a pretty simple idea this is a cost
benefit analysis set on a grid right
there's nothing there's nothing
groundbreaking here uh it is uh it's
useful and I I will encourage you to use
it or something like it uh but I I don't
want to pretend like I have invented the
wheel here because I I have not this is
this is a simple idea so what's the
point why why am I telling you this I
think the really useful piece of this is
that it is a hand chair it is a hand
chair because to me a hand chair is the
definitive example of a conversation
piece right I can't imagine walking into
someone's home and seeing one of those
and not having a conversation about it
and that's what I want you to think of
when you when you see the Gonzalez
Matrix right is all of the questions
that pop into my mind when you see a
hand chair when I see a hand share I
want you to have all of those questions
for all of that to come up when you
think about your projects or your tasks
laid out on a matrix uh and then to have
that conversation in a structured and
productive and helpful way so that's
really what I'm trying to give you here
is is the permission and encouragement
and structure in which you can have a
conversation that will be helpful for
you and for your team
okay uh hand shars does anybody have a
hand
shair I would I really I have questions
please come find me if you
do uh so I've been talking about a
conversation right it's a conversation
piece that's how want you to think about
this and and that's true but I I want to
acknowledge that uh some people use the
word conversation as a euphemism for
conflict right uh that happens uh I'm a
family therapist by training I have I've
seen that happen uh so I I want to
acknowledge that conversations are not
necessarily always easy or perfect uh
this is actually meant to prevent
conflict in in that we're trying to make
explicit things that are implicit and
lead to conflict uh but but again I I
know it's not perfectly easy to do so
and so I I want to acknowledge that uh
and so here I'm going to give you some
some guidelines and set some
expectations for what I what I think you
can uh you know expect to see as you go
through this first uh how should you
talk about effort and value right uh
what what is the right way to have this
conversation at a very high level I
would say uh you want to be systematic
you want to be transparent and you want
to be
open-minded uh systematic and that this
is an iterative exercise you're going to
come back to this a time and time again
every time a new project pops up maybe
or on some regular schedule uh and you
to do it the same way as you go through
it each time because that consistency
will allow the people on your team to
have that sort of mental model right
that that prediction about how this is
going to go each time and to get better
at guessing how how projects are going
to be rated on effort and value and so
so that's important to be systematic in
that way uh transparently also because
if we are you know driven by some some
internal bias Something That We're Not
acknowledging in our rating of effort
and value uh that's going to be clear to
people they're going to know that
something is off between what you're
saying what you're describing about a
particular project and how you're rating
it and and that Gap that people are
going to feel is going to quash the
conversation which is the opposite of
what we want and so you you need to be
transparent about uh you know I don't
like working with project team X so I'm
going to rate this as not very valuable
or super effortful uh if you are not
saying that aloud uh people will notice
and it will it will sort of backfire on
you so just be transparent about why
you're giving the ratings that you are
and hopefully within your team it's safe
to have that kind of transparency uh and
then finally open-mindedly because uh I
promise you people on your team know
things about effort and value that you
do not uh you know for instance uh my
boss is a great data person she's a long
way uh off in her career from being
hands- on keyboard right she doesn't
spend a whole lot of time actually
working with data any longer uh so the
analysts on our team I they they know a
lot more about how effortful a
particular analysis will be than she
does at this point uh whereas I you know
me and the other analysts on the team
will have a lot less view into how
valuable something is at the
organization level right so she has that
and uh can can bring that to
us uh thinking a little bit more rubber
meets the road about effort and value
you want to assess the contextual
factors right this is this is how you're
going to really determine effort and
value in a systematic way is thinking
about at the organization level uh how
well does a particular project line up
with the mission and vision right or uh
does your team maybe have some
competitive Advantage something that you
do particularly well uh that's going to
help you produce value and that you can
use to sort of determine where a project
falls on those uh on those attributes or
maybe you have a key partner who is
going to make a project really easy on
you or make a particular project really
valuable for your team right so thinking
about that uh as a way to to determine
what's effortful and what's
valuable and then finally uh this has
been a very data like talk for a data
science conference uh but here I want to
I want to bring it in a little bit and
just say that if you were tracking your
time and your effort and your uh and
your impact you the value you're
producing with a given project you can
use that to calibrate and go back over
time in this iterative exercise to
determine you know were you write right
have you accurately predicted how
effortful and valuable something will be
uh and where you're off you can you can
tweak you can adjust how you're doing
this to make yourself better at it next
uh challenges you can expect uh just a
few things that I have seen uh first and
some of you might be feeling this
already the resistance to dropping
projects right uh as I said I think
there's some really good reasons we have
this uh but but recog izing this
resistance and tracking whether it's
it's you or somebody else on the team or
if it's a mix uh tracking you know what
kind of projects it seems to come up
around um is really going to be useful
information so so that feeling of
resistance to dropping a project is is
just worth paying attention to and I I
don't have a magic answer for it other
than to say if you see the pattern uh
over time you will you will start to
recognize that that uh you can do
something about that pattern I I don't
know what that is exactly um but it is
the kind of paying attention to it
paying attention of the resistance
listening to it that will get you
something
valuable uh different perspectives as I
said different team members are going to
see effort and value of a given project
in different ways and that's okay that's
uh that is useful uh but you do need to
be prepared to to uh you know let people
know if if your decision is the final
one that needs to be clear going into
this if this is a democratic process in
which everybody's vote counts the same
that needs to be clear too so there's
not a right or wrong way to do it uh but
acknowledging that these differences are
going to play out in one of one of a few
ways uh is important to do ahead of time
uh and then finally the need for
flexibility uh you know people might
want things that do not necessarily
align with this uh with this Matrix with
this grid um and so being ready if you
have the flexibility to to to exercise
it right to say okay we can spend time
on this because you really want to and
that is okay even though it it doesn't
line up necessarily with our ratings uh
or if you can't acknowledging that ahead
of time saying no we we are too strapped
we we need to focus uh in exactly the
way that is prescribed so being ready
for that uh finally why I know this is a
little late for this in the talk but I'd
say how does this help it helps in a few
ways um one is uh it limits this
everything as critical mindset right
everything might be critical but not
everything can be equally critical and
that's really what this exercise is
about uh this is really the how you say
no to your boss right you ask them for
help prioritizing so that you can focus
uh it also is going to get everybody
rowing in the same direction as they say
uh if you can align your team's
perspective and and clarify
responsibilities get everybody to think
the same way about what's valuable uh
you will really really produce a whole
lot more uh than if you all kind of
spinning wheels independently and maybe
even going different directions so that
is uh that is a really important benefit
um and it's part of why doing less can
actually make you more productive in
addition to just feeling
better and then finally uh this is a
really good training ground for teaching
Junior folks to to communicate and to to
uh you know be willing to voice their
perspective on this stuff we we want our
Junior folks uh to get that kind of
training and as Andrew so so beautifully
spoke about uh it is is uh you know not
born in any of us so we need to uh we
need to give them the space to learn
that and this exercise is a great way to
do that uh wrapping up with a quick
summary here's what I am I'm proposing
to you basically is that you get that
flood of messages in your inbox and you
feel overwhelmed I think it's actually a
little bit different I think there's a a
cognitive path here that goes from flood
of messages to fomo to too many projects
to feeling overwhelmed and that by
recognizing the fomo putting it in its
place with the Gonzalez Matrix and then
calling projects and feeling better gets
you actually from flood of messages uh
more directly to this feeling of
Serenity Now and productivity later
thank
[Applause]
you